but the things have
changed so I just want you and and
anybody can say out loud except Richard
because Richard knows what I'm going to
do but if I say to you what what style
is
this if I say what style is
this
right if I if I had a person out here
Richard Richard
I need
you if I
said this do you know what style it isy
key style yeah what
G key style right
so so there's all these
Styles but you sometimes but
ensei had only ensi style and yet he
taught Koshi to key style he taught goo
shoda he taught cyto sensy so today's um
seminar is about hands shape of hands
when you've been doing like it over a
few years you'll say I'm supposed to be
using my body not my hands but the
problem is we do use our hands so don't
sort of like try and use your body and
think that your hands are not got to be
used so today when I do tanah hener I
say look at both hands look at the
fingers is one limp one Dynamic so this
if I put it this way if I put it that
way you recognize it as IW style if I
put it this way you might not recognize
it IW
style what one was this y but what look
at that
hands those of you who SE O sense's
pictures and
that you know so these hands are what
we're going to look at
today okay
so we're going to do
iamy and we're going to do first of all
shagi so you all know shagi now most
people take this hand and it's there's
no warmer hands
here you see they're they're limp hands
but you've got to get this Thumb
in on the top but most people put that
hand on first and then their thumb goes
a little bit higher and if he makes a
strong move this arm will bend it has to
bend because it can't be strong now the
stupid thing is if I put the thumb there
and just clamp with my top H when he
blocks the arm don't
bend just a few inches away it's
ridiculous but that's that's aid though
it's very technical it's very
precise it's very powerful
because it's very powerful because it's
the technique that's strong I don't have
to be but if I get something in the
wrong place then I have to be
strong so so watch
again there's the coke you
hand there's the thumb then it clamps
and then you
do if you have a bad injury or a problem
tell your partner I won't take the ukis
that's okay with you we're looking at
the first part okay done